you guys aren't on a red carpet every
night i'm assuming so how does it feel
to be here is it like weird i'm very
top-heavy right now and i'm a little
shaky it's very surreal is this a date
night for you yes it's a it's a much
needed date night we don't get out much
later we flew in this morning our flight
got canceled we literally just landed
and then we're on a red eye out so what
a date night
are the kids in l.a or is this just
purely a romantic trip yes romantic trip
no kids but i'm already pregnant so
we're not sorry about that happening
again how how are you feeling with the
pregnancy this is the third right third
in three years i've been pregnant since
2019. all right pal i'm putting in the
work putting in the work
you i'm putting in the work in heels
right now come on are you feeling great
i am i really am i feel very different
this time around so thank you so
nominated for best reality romance you
guys got some amazing competition but
what does it feel like to be recognized
it's crazy like we never thought about
all any of this obviously first time
here first time on like a red carpet and
it's just we're just good
it is we're just us
now are cameras following everything
with this next pregnancy you will see
more
now are you gonna let the cameras in the
delivery room when it finally happens
well i'm having a c-section i know so
maybe maybe not we'll see what they say
at the hospital this time that's great
for tv because it's scheduled ahead of
time you know they both the other two
were and well we'll see how that
happened
[Music]